we're going to talk now about the right
wing media propaganda cycle this is not
dissimilar to money laundering in a
sense where the money starts dirty and
ends up clean maybe not a Perfect
Analogy but let's think through the
cycle how does the right Force nonsense
and imaginary issues
into what we might call the mainstream
of the political media discussion the
first step is get some coverage of your
crazy idea or claim somewhere even if it
is not reporting it as if it's true
but reporting that you said it either
way is good and it starts the propaganda
cycle so it might start for example in a
small local news Outlet of some kind
maybe you you'll have a local reporter
tweeting about it and often it will come
from some kind of small time news agency
often understaffed they don't have the
resources to fact check every story
they've got tight deadlines and pressure
from editors so they've got to pump
stuff out so if you can plant a rumor on
one of those platforms you're already
well on your way to starting this cycle
of right-wing propaganda and this could
be you know there are there are cat
litter boxes in the bathrooms at some
schools for the students who identify as
cats that's that's one possibility get
something written about it somewhere get
tweets from reporters even if it's just
it is being claimed that this is going
on
the second step is you take those tweets
or local news articles or whatever the
case may be and you then use social
media to amplify it based on those
initial bits of reporting you use that
to generate more attention about it
because as we know there are so many
people on Twitter that if they see
Marjorie Taylor green or whoever retweet
something that says they've got cat
litter boxes in schools for students who
identify as cats
95 of the people who see it and retweet
it won't check what is the original
Source my I always tell you critically
analyze primary sources to try to
understand what you're being fed you can
use that initial thing to then amplify
it on social media and then it'll take
on a life of its own social media
becomes a great breeding ground for
amplifying rumor and conspiracy theory
even better if you know how to use Bots
and trolls you can get the rumors to
spread like wildfire and before you know
it they've gone viral on Twitter on
Reddit wherever the case may be
step three is you want to upgrade the
credibility of the propaganda through an
outlet like maybe an oan or a Newsmax
with the goal of eventually getting it
onto Fox News where the likes of Tucker
Carlson can bring it up not yet
reporting on it but asking questions
right and this is a classic propaganda
technique starts with some local news
story based on conjecture Amplified on
social media by Republicans and then
Tucker says listen
um we need to be allowed to ask
questions about cat cat litter boxes in
school bathrooms the American people
have a right to know about cat litter
boxes in bathrooms and the left doesn't
want to talk about it well maybe the
left doesn't want to talk about it
because there's no evidence that's the
third step in the cycle we need to be
allowed to talk about this and if you
can argue that someone is trying to stop
you from talking about it even better
then you get to the fourth step which is
sort of what we saw yesterday in the
hearing from which we saw Clips earlier
in the show with Marjorie Taylor green
politicians need to start demanding
answers and maybe they'll hold a hearing
and instead of actually asking questions
they just rant and rant and rant and
it's all because the public has a right
to know and this is where these
propaganda stories can really gain
momentum once politicians get involved
in a formal way the rumor is now a story
even if it was always based on nothing
and the media can't ignore it in this
case it's about you know Majorca slide
and all these different things the last
step
is you cement the rumor for an election
cycle by just sort of keeping it going
long enough and that's when it becomes
fact in the minds of many people the
longer you can keep it in the news cycle
the more that a large portion of the
electorate will believe that it is true
it starts to be referred to as truth and
then it can last an entire election
cycle or longer there are so many causes
of this propaganda cycle
but Marjorie Taylor green has added this
new layer which is you just yell the
conspiracy theories at a witness to whom
you're supposed to be asking questions
that is now the epitome of this so what
should we do what can we do the most
important thing is to understand the
cycle and remember if everybody
understood critically analyze primary
sources before you retweet before you
fall for it before you start talking
about it as if it's true if everybody
understood that if we were Vigilant if
we actually tried to understand where we
are getting these claims from we would
be able to short-circuit these
propaganda Cycles getting going in the
first place of course due to a lack of
media literacy hyper partisanship and
lack of uh of of education and so much
ignorance that we see it's very hard to
short-circuit it but this is the anatomy
of that cycle and Marjory Taylor green
sort of knows how to take advantage of
it that's for sure we'll have all of the
clips I played today
on our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and of course on our
YouTube channel make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show